mr speaker we are indeed all on the same
side in fighting
this virus and i hope the secretary of
state understands that when we raise
issues we do so
because we urge the government to
improve its response to fighting
this virus because this remains a lethal
virus
and for many it leaves them with serious
debilitating
sickness so everything must be done to
drive down
and eliminate infections and and
suppress
the virus completely with that in mind i
hope the secretary of state can answer a
few
questions uh today and i'm grateful for
his
advance for advanced site of his
statement
first of all in order to avoid a second
national lockdown which we all want to
avoid
an effective test and tracing regime
is absolutely vital i listened carefully
to the figures that he outlined
but he didn't tell the house that of the
numbers actually going into the system
they have actually fallen in the last
week down from 79
down to 72 this system
is not yet world beating throughout
questions he's
rejected criticisms of the private
sector contracts
uh contractors who are involved in
delivering this system so there's no
point in me
raising that again but the fundamental
point is wouldn't it not be better
if money was spent investing in local
public health teams
particularly in those areas where there
are restrictions in place
so they can do more door-to-door testing
as we've seen for example
in leicester surely that would be a
better use of public funding for example
than paying for so-called influencers on
instagram
to pick up test and trace now
on testing itself he now supports mass
testing as a policy aim it's something
i've been calling for for some months
it's something the former health
secretary of the chair of the health
sector committee
has been calling for indeed we try to
persuade him
of its merits before the summer when we
asked him to introduce regular testing
of nhs frontline staff he whipped his
mps
to vote against it but will he now given
that he's in favor of mass testing
introduce regular weekly testing of all
frontline nhs workers but to move to
mass testing
means evol evolving our testing regime
from one
which provides antibody tests and the
diagnostic pcr tests
to affect effectively a system of mass
screening
using more rapid on-the-spot antigen
tests
he referred to rapid tests in his
statement can he tell us
when rapid on-the-spot antigen tests
will be rolled out
across society and which sectors of the
workforce
will be first in the queue to access
those rapid on-the-spot
antigen tests well they now also look at
introducing saliva testing it's being
used
in hong kong for example it will ensure
the quick turnaround of tests
and i wonder if he's seen the street
street from yale that
suggests saliva testing could be as
sensitive
as the nose and throat swabs what is his
attitude towards
pool testing because pool testing would
surely increase the capacity
in areas of low prevalence does he have
a plan to introduce
pooled testing he's right that we are
investing in public health teams and so
we should
and as we discussed in questions it's
important to have the combination
of the the national system and
the local it's also very important that
we communicate
to people that it's important to engage
in testing
and the contact tracing for those who
are who test positive in their contacts
and so being able to communicate to
people so that they get those messages
is very important
and we'll do that in whatever way is
effective to get those messages
across um he asks about the importance
of mass testing
um i have been i bow to no one
in my enthusiasm for mass testing i'm
very glad that he
supports my drive for mass testing uh
he's
um he might remember the exchanges that
we had some time ago when
i rather stuck my neck out in pushing
for mass testing
when we needed to get to hundreds of
thousands of tests well we need to
increase the number of tests again um he
mentioned both saliva tests and pool
tests
uh we're trialing both of those uh but
as with vaccines which i'll come on to
briefly mr speaker we will only use
testing
that is validated and that is where the
results are
safe so it's important that we use
the the world-class facilities that we
have at port and down
to make sure that tests are validated
before we use them in public
but saliva testing and pool testing are
both both
options that we are that we are working
on
when it comes to local lockdowns mr
speaker local lockdowns are
working this local action again jointly
between national and local government
is having an effect and he knows this
well from leicester where the
case rate is right down we absolutely do
publish the data on which these
decisions are made
and in fact from last thursday now
published data
at lower super output area which is the
lowest level in terms of how local the
test results can be
reasonably published and we have
extensive data provided to directors of
public health